TARGET.
BUT GLASGOW IS A CRITICAL
MILESTONE BUT THERE'S GOING TO
BE A LOT OF WORK FOLLOWING FROM
GLASGOW.
>> PRESIDENT BIDEN SAID AT CNN'S
TOWN HALL LAST WEEK THAT THE
U.S. WOULD COME TO TAIWAN'S
DEFENSE IF CHINA INVADED.
YOUR SPOKESPERSON SAID THERE'S
NO CHANGE IN U.S. POSITION SO
JUST WANT TO CLARIFY, HAS THE
U.S. COMMITTED DIRECTLY TO THE
TAIWANESE GOVERNMENT THAT IT
WILL COME TO TAIWAN'S DEFENSE IF
CHINA INVADES?
>> THERE IS NO CHANGE IN OUR
POLICY.
WE'VE HAD A LANGLONGSTANDING
COMMITMENT SENATOR BIDEN
SUPPORTED WHEN HE WAS IN THE
SENATE, LONGSTANDING COMMITMENT
TO MAKE SURE TAIWAN HAS THE
MEANS TO DEFEND ITSELF AND WE
STAND BY THAT.
THE PRESIDENT STOOD BY THAT
STRONGLY AND WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE NO ONE TAKES UNILATERAL
ACTION TO DISRUPT THE STATUS QUO
OF TAIWAN.
>> YOU ARE THE SECRETARY OF
STATE AND THAT WAS PERFECT DIPLO
SPEAK SO I WANTED, FOR PEOPLE
WHO DON'T SPEAK THAT LANGUAGE,
CAN YOU CLARIFY WHAT THAT MEANS.
ARE YOU SAYING THE UNITED STATES
WOULD NOT COME TO TAIWAN'S
DEFENSE IF ATTACKED?
CAN YOU BE SPECIFIC?
YES OR NO?
>> DANA, AGAIN WE REMAIN
COMMITTED RESOLUTELY COMMITTED
TO OUR RESPONSIBILITIES UNDER
THE TAIWAN RELATIONS ACT,
INCLUDING MAKING SURE THAT
TAIWAN HAS THE ABILITY TO DEFEND
ITSELF FROM ANY AGGRESSION.
>> OKAY.
JUST ONE MORE FOLLOW ON THAT,
THE PRESIDENT SAID SPECIFICALLY
THAT THE U.S., THAT'S NOT WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING, CORRECT?
>> THE PRESIDENT HAS FOR A LONG
TIME, INCLUDING WHEN HE WAS A
SENATOR, VOTING FOR THE TAIWAN
RELATIONS ACT, MADE CLEAR THAT
WE WILL DO EVERYTHING NECESSARY
TO MAKE SURE THAT TAIWAN HAS THE
MEANS TO DEFEND ITSELF.
>> LET'S TALK ABOUT IRAN.
THE G20 IS ADDRESSING THE THREAT
OF IRANIAN NUCLEAR WEAPONS AHEAD
OF RENEWED NEGOTIATIONS ABOUT
THE NUCLEAR DEAL IN VIENNA.
IS THE U.S. PREPARED TO INCREASE
PRESSURE ON IRAN TO GET THEM
BACK TO THE TABLE AND IF SO,
WHAT DOES THAT PRESSURE LOOK
LIKE?
>> WELL, TWO THINGS.
FIRST, PRESIDENT BIDEN GOT
TOGETHER HERE IN ROME WITH HIS
GERMAN, HIS FRENCH AND HIS
BRITISH COUNTERPARTS.
WE ARE ABSOLUTELY IN LOCK STEP
TOGETHER ON HOW WE'RE
APPROACHING THE CHALLENGE OF
GETTING IRAN BACK INTO
COMPLIANCE WITH THE NUCLEAR
AGREEMENT AND THAT'S NEW BECAUSE
WE'D BEEN AT ODDS IN RECENT
YEARS OVER THAT WHEN THE UNITED
STATES PULLED OUT OF THE
AGREEMENT.
>> WHAT IS THAT LOCK STEP?
WHAT DOES IT LOOK LIKE?
>> WE'RE WORKING ON THIS
TOGETHER.
TWO THINGS.
WE CONTINUE TO BELIEVE THE
DIPLOMACY IS THE BEST WAY TO
DEAL WITH THE CHALLENGES, THREAT
POSED BY IRAN'S NUCLEAR PROGRAM
AND IN PARTICULAR, PARTICULARLY
UNFORTUNATELY THE STEPS IT'S
TAKEN SINCE WE PULLED OUT IN
RECENT MONTHS TO MAKE THAT
PROGRAM INCREASINGLY DANGEROUS.
THERE'S STILL A WINDOW THROUGH
WHICH IRAN CAN COME BACK TO THE
TALKS AND WE CAN COME BACK TO
MUTUAL COMPLIANCE WITH THE
AGREEMENT AND THAT WOULD BE THE
BEST RESULT, BUT IT REALLY
DEPENDS ON WHETHER IRAN IS
SERIOUS ABOUT DOING THAT.
ALL OF OUR COUNTRIES WORKING BY
THE WAY WITH RUSSIA AND CHINA
BELIEVE STRONGLY THAT WOULD BE
THE BEST PATH FORWARD BUT WE DO
NOT KNOW WHETHER IRAN IS WILLING
TO COME BACK AND TO ENGAGE IN A
MEANINGFUL WAY AND GET BACK INTO
LINE.
IF IT ISN'T, IF IT WON'T, WE ARE
LOOKING TOGETHER AT ALL OF THE
OPTIONS NECESSARY TO DEAL WITH
THIS PROBLEM.
>> I ALSO WANT TO ASK ABOUT
AFGHANISTAN.
I WANT YOU TO LISTEN TO OUR
VIEWERS TO LISTEN TO WHAT YOU
SAID TWO MONTHS AGO ABOUT
AMERICANS STILL IN AFGHANISTAN.
>> WE BELIEVE THERE ARE STILL A
SMALL NUMBER OF AMERICANS UNDER
200 AND LIKELY CLOSER TO 100 WHO
REMAIN IN AFGHANISTAN AND WANT
TO LEAVE.
>> SO WE NOW BELIEVE THERE ARE
STILL CLOSE TO 200 AMERICANS
TRYING TO GET OUT OF
AFGHANISTAN, EVEN AFTER YOU
EVACUATED MORE THAN 200 ALREADY.
IS IT ACCEPTABLE SO MANY
AMERICANS ARE TWO MONTHS LATER
TRYING TO GET OUT OF
AFGHANISTAN?
>> DANA, LET'S BE VERY CLEAR
ABOUT THIS BECAUSE I THINK
THERE'S A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF
CONFUSION ABOUT THIS ISSUE
THAT'S BUILT UP IN RECENT MONTHS
AND GIVE ME ONE SECOND AND I'LL
TRY AND EXPLAIN IT.
FIRST, GOING BACK TO MARCH OF
THIS YEAR, WELL BEFORE THE
PRESIDENT MADE HIS DECISION,
WELL BEFORE AFGHANISTAN
IMPLODED, THE GOVERNMENT AND THE
MILITARY IMPLODED WE STARTED
SENDING MESSAGES TO THOSE WHO
THIS AMERICAN PASSPORTS IN
AFGHANISTAN, 19 BETWEEN MARCH
AND JULY URGING THEM TO LEAVE
THE COUNTRY.
BY THE TIME THE GOVERNMENT DID
IMPLODE, IN AUGUST, THERE WERE
STILL ABOUT 6,000 LEFT, AND
THERE'S A GOOD REASON FOR THAT.
THESE ARE PEOPLE WHOSE ENTIRE
LIVES WERE IN AFGHANISTAN.
THEIR FAMILIES WERE THERE,
EXTENDED FAMILIES WERE THERE.
THAT'S WHAT THEY KNEW AND SO
IT'S AN INCREDIBLY WRENCHING
DECISION TO LEAVE.
SO ABOUT 6,000 LEFT AT THAT
POINT.
DURING THE EVACUATION, THE
EXTRAORDINARY EVACUATION WE GOT
ABOUT 125,000 PEOPLE OUT OF
AFGHANISTAN WE GOT VIRTUALLY ALL
OF THE 6,000 WHO REMAINED OUT.
THERE WERE STILL SEVERAL HUNDRED
WHO TOLD US AT THAT POINT THEY
WANTED TO GET OUT WHO WERE NOT
ABLE TO GET OUT BY THE 31st.
WE SAID THERE'S NO DEADLINE TO
THIS EFFORT.
WE'LL CONTINUE TO GET THEM OUT.
SINCE AUGUST 31st, AS OF TODAY,
WE'VE GOTTEN OUT OF THE
AMERICANS LEFT WHO SAID THEY
WANTED TO LEAVE ABOUT 340, BUT
WHAT'S HAPPENED SINCE IS THIS.
MORE PEOPLE HAVE COME FORWARD IN
TWO WAYS.
THERE WERE SOME SMALL NUMBER OF
AMERICANS IN AFGHANISTAN WHO
DIDN'T WANT TO LEAVE WHO HAVE
NOW SEEN THAT WE'VE SUCCESSFULLY
BEEN ABLE TO GET SOME OF THE FEW
REMAINING AMERICANS OUT WHO HAVE
NOW COME FORWARD AND SAID WE DO
WANT TO LEAVE AND A COUPLE
HUNDRED OF THOSE WHO ARE READY
TO LEAVE AND WE WILL WORK TO GET
THEM OUT.
SIMILARLY, SINCES AFR AUGUST
31st, OTHER PEOPLE HAVE COME
FORWARD NOT IDENTIFIED HAVING AN
AMERICAN PASSPORT, THEY SAID
THEY DO.
WE VERIFIED THAT.
IF THEY SAY THEY WANT TO COME
OUT WE BRING THEM OUT AS WELL.
WE DEMONSTRATED EXACTLY WHAT WE
SAID.
IN AUGUST, EVEN AS WE WORKED TO
GET AS MANY PEOPLE OUT AS WE
COULD, BEFORE WE LEFT THE
AIRPORT WE WERE CONVINCED WE'D